crazy that's rude you just put your hand
up as if you've done that no I was gonna
say
so knowing that do you think that men
should date women with lower body counts
how would that impact it though because
what if it's just one guy and the guy
was slapping the brakes off and was
doing a Madness
I'm asking you
um
now I don't think that really has a
bearing you don't think body count
matters no I think body counts matters
but I don't think that has a bearing of
whether she's going to think about it
because she's going to think about him
if she's not satisfied so it's more
about are you throwing it down like you
should definitely yeah but the more
people she slept with the less likely
like if she's like no if she slept with
50 dudes you think you're gonna be the
best out of 50 dudes but the thing is
obviously I hope so she has to hold back
in my previous life out of 50. I'd
experience I'd experience slinging my
weedy round and do my nightstands but
it's not actually good sex and it
doesn't mean good at six like you
probably have the most enjoyable sex
when it's with one person I'd say
so it all depends really it comes down
to you have to be super accountable and
look at yourself and just like do I have
magic fingers or am I Mr flaccid that am
I doing what I need to do yeah really
and truly that's a very blue pill
ideology that's like men need to step up
no I think well I suppose if you can say
it's pretty pill but it's just like yeah
the reality is if me as a man I can't
make my woman be able to think about
just me yeah then well why wouldn't you
pick a girl that you don't have to deal
with that bag did oh yeah 100 yeah 100
but what I'm saying is even if you're
saying that baggage but say even if she
slept with water like what if
the size is just different and you can't
control yeah but then it comes then it
comes to accountability if I picked the
wrong one lack you need to pick the one
for you and if if she's not satisfied by
me they're signs you know when a girl
wants to sleep with you and nosy Fielder
one or not so really it comes down to
wow my experiences
I I think that most girls can pull one
over at a guy I think most guys think
they're smarter than they are in my
opinion like I think only the only
people that really know is her close
friends where you fall yeah I I agree
with you on that one yeah because I've
seen it where like I've seen a girl like
a guy or so what somewhat like a guy and
then when I've seen her with another guy
that she really likes her behavior her
mannerisms she won't even come up and
say hi to guy friends that she she will
like act accordingly and I'm like okay
so this is what it looks like when she
really likes someone and that's so not
it changed the game for me like a red
pill moment because even I I think most
girls can trick a guy into like thinking
yeah like yeah like and I always tell
this story so there's a girl that I knew
in college I might have you might have
heard this already but so there's a girl
I knew in college and basically her
freshman year of college she dated the
bad boy right senior year She's Dating
the nice guy man bought her a house
I mean I just think it was like the next
step they've been dating a little bit
because remember this is like three four
years later right okay so you know she's
been dating him for a minute no bring no
not just house
I didn't I didn't I mean they're 21 I
don't know I just know she and him moved
into a house
and
I'm at a party my senior year of college
and I see her walk out of the bathroom
with the guy from freshman year it
happens
and it was crazy because an hour later
the new guy shows up I feel bad for him
and so that's why I I say the girl the
guy that she complains about like that's
the one that got her
um
there's the saying of the god fear Eve
because women can actually just lie to
you like that I don't I can't believe he
wouldn't notice anything I mean so
that's all like any of that behavior no
I think I think women cheat more
effectively see if Amanda machines are
sloppy sloppy you see a woman the way
she'll cheat you you won't even believe
like it's it's ever possible that's
scary
what's that okay and Jess have you ever
seen a girl cheat yeah what's the
craziest thing you've seen someone cheat
hmm
I'm trying to think
he's like what is the craziest
um oh I had a friend who was dating a
dude
and she had another dude asking to fly
her out and fly her out to another state
go hang out with him dinner everything
and she was contemplating it and I'm
like if you're in this relationship with
the dude she's like I think I'm gonna do
it and I was like okay
all right that's that's your choice you
know it's bad like you're in a
relationship with a dude but you're
gonna get floating out by this guy she's
like oh we're not gonna do anything I
was like all right okay
have a dinner and then go back to an
Airbnb and chill she's like I think I'm
gonna do it I was like
okay have you guys ever seen a girl
cheat
no not Brady no loads of times
like loads of time like with you
[Laughter]
the funniest thing is guys will tell me
they'll be like the I didn't realize how
how bad women were until I was the guy
she cheated with yeah because like
random used to turn it into a game like
growing up it used to be like oh I like
you know the whole Mr Studio girl like
stuff like that yeah I remember a person
who remained nameless
they were out and then they secured the
girl on the night out or the lady I
should say
and gone to the car
she's glogging him off doing a throat go
business in the car
um the husband's called he's just like
I'll pick you up
she's finished off
the guy and then she's got and picked up
by me and she drove home and she's happy
satisfied
oh my God
do you think men cheat as bad
not as bad because men are sloppy like
if your man's cheating you probably know
deep down you probably know that he's
cheating yeah like women always have a
hunch exactly I would agree to that yeah
would you would you guys be willing to
share a guy if if he had everything he
wanted he loved you but just now and
then he would step out
just arrives
me and me and Jess are on a two for one
special
get it while you can yeah Sister Wives
did you actually do that
no no no no no
you might I might okay why tell me why I
don't
I think monogamy is very hard I think
long term man and women or so are you
talking open relationship what are you
talking about on his end
um it would have to be both oh it has to
be nice yeah it would have to be so we
still love sorry
could you still because a lot of a man
we've had the conversation before a man
can love a woman and throw his Willy
about and fall into vagina from time to
time but a lot of women they can't do
that so would you could you say that you
could still love the guy you're with and
still be open in a relationship in my
mind
I think after a certain amount of years
5 10 maybe 20 years yes in the beginning
early phases I don't think
I could because that possessive like
need to claim is there but I think
eventually I